Історичне рішення. Німецький Бундестаг визнав Голодомор 1932-33 років геноцидом українського народу.
На пленарному засіданні 30 листопада парламентарі від правлячої коаліції -
соціал-демократи, " зелені" і ліберали, а також опозиційні консерватори -
одноголосно підтримали відповідну постанову.
Ліва партія і права АдН утрималися.
У резолюції сказано, що від голоду і репресій потерпала ціла Україна, а не лише хліборобні регіони.
Тому нині напрошується історико-політична оцінка Голодомору як геноциду, наголошується у постанові.
Геноцидом Голодомор визнали вже понад 20 держав світу.
Це і сусіди України, і держави-члени ЄС, і США, і країни Латинської Америки.
Минулого тижня приєдналися Ірландія і Молдова.
У Румунії трагедію назвали злочином проти людяності.
У цьому переліку бракувало найвпливовіших європейських держав, зокрема Німеччини.
Переконати Берлін визнати Голодомор геноцидом Україна намагалася ще з середини 2000-х років.
Утім, у Бундестазі не знаходилося голосів для такої резолюції.
Ситуація змінилася після початку повномасштабного вторгнення РФ в Україну.
Адже це свідчення того, що Росія нині повертається до старих практик,
каже Робін Ваґенер, співавтор постанови про визнання Голодомору геноцидом.
Голодомор - це жахливий сталінський злочин, метою якого було винищення української культури, української нації.
Нині ми саме знову перебуваємо у ситуації, коли російський напад має таку саму мету.
Тому нині саме час повернутися до злочинів минулого і згадати про них,
вшанувати пам'ять вбитих і застерегти суспільство, що треба зараз нарешті зробити висновки.
А також діяти зараз, щоби зупинити російський терор і підтримати Україну.
З німецьких топ-політиків термін "геноцид" в контексті Голодомору вперше використала
очільниця німецької дипломатії Анналена Бербок у своєму твіті напередодні 90-ої річниці Голодомору.
У Голодоморі мільйони українців загинули, бо їх систематично морили голодом.
Дякую @ДмитроКулеба за ваш імпульс - назвати цей злочин його нинішньою назвою: геноцид.
Дякую всім, хто просував це в німецькому Бундестазі.
А німецький канцлер Олаф Шольц у день річниці Голодомору провів паралелі із зерновою кризою,
яку спричинила Росія нині, й назвав голод неприпустимою зброєю.
Масовий голод, спровокований Сталіним, став причиною смерті понад трьох мільйонів людей.
Жахлива тактика, яка застосовувалася в ті роки, включала ізоляцію, конфіскацію зерна та примусові депортації українців.
Сьогодні ми разом заявляємо про те, що голод не можна використовувати як зброю.
Це причина, через яку нам не можна терпіти те, що ми бачимо.
В інтерв'ю DW резолюцію щодо Голодомору прокоментував й президент ФРН Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр.
Він подякував Бундестагу за поступ у цьому питанні.
Голодомор - це злочин, про який у Німеччині відносно мало знають.
Ми повинні пам'ятати, що саме Україна була жертвою цього катастрофічного голоду.
І цей катастрофічний голод не був наслідком неврожаю,
як це десятиліттями казала передусім російська історична наука.
Натомість це була цілеспрямована стратегія сталінського режиму -
змусити голодувати частину населення колишнього Радянського Союзу, аби вони стали покірними.
Роками в Німеччині звучали різні аргументи проти визнання Голодомору геноцидом українців.
В уряді ФРН раніше відзначали, що не можна називати геноцидом злочини, скоєні до 1951 року.
Адже лише тоді ООН дала визначення самого терміну "геноцид".
Водночас ФРН у 2016 році визнала геноцидом масове вбивство вірменів у 1915 році Османською імперією.
Ще одним аргументом скептиків була думка, що голод зачепив не лише українців,
а й інші народи, зокрема в Росії і на Кавказі.
Свою роль відігравало й те, що чимало німецьких політиків побоювалися,
що визнання Голодомору зіпсує відносини з Росією.
Нині ж перестороги зайвий раз не дратувати Москву, вочевидь, втратили значимість.
Я переконаний, що, звісно ж, актуальна ситуація з війною відіграє особливу роль.
А саме, у тому сенсі, що ми бачимо значно ширшу готовність також серед політичних еліт
цей дуже чутливий і трагічний пункт української історії більше не розглядати без надмірної оглядки на Росію.
Адже ми знаємо, що Росія заперечує Голодомор, а прагнення України досягти визнання його геноцидом
і насамперед підтримку цього на Заході інтерпретує як русофобну політику.
У своїй постанові Бундестаг, зокрема, закликав поширювати в суспільстві знання про Голодомор
як про злочин проти українців і більше говорити про нього в школах.
Поки це лише рекомендація. Історик Вільфрід Їльґе сподівається, що уряд втілить її у життя.
Не може бути ситуації, щоб ми дивилися на історію, на національне самоствердження країн-сусідів через російські окуляри.
Тепер важливо, щоб ми не лише мали цю резолюцію, але щоб ця історична подія
була також відображена в підручниках історії,
щоб про цю українську трагедію в Німеччині знали не лише у колах істориків чи експертів, але й на рівні суспільства.
Вільфрід Їльґе вірить, що в майбутньому в Росії теж прийдуть до визнання відповідальності за злочини радянського минулого.
Водночас, щоб зупинити трагедію, яка розгортається просто зараз,
Німеччині варто давати Україні більше зброї, певен співавтор постанови про визнання Голодомору геноцидом Робін Ваґенер.
Мають постачатися й танки та бронемашини, аби допомогти звільняти території.
Адже навесні Росія здійснюватиме чергову спробу наступу.
Україна має бути до цього готовою, але й має бути в змозі звільняти свою землю,
захищати суверенітет і унеможливити воєнні злочини.
Німеччина має надавати потужну комплексну підтримку - гуманітарну, економічну і військову.
Потрібно зберігати дієві санкції і докладати зусиль для покарання за воєнні злочини.
Робін Ваґенер поки не називає нинішню війну геноцидом.
На думку політика, це справа істориків і юристів, хоча паралелі з подіями 30-х, за його словами, очевидні.
Хоча німецькі історики обережніші і вважають недоречним порівнювати Голодомор і війну.